Sorry I was late.
For the stream.
Sorry.
Sorry I was late.
And sorry that my... I don't know why the music was muted in the beginning.
I have no idea.
That is so weird.
That is so weird!
I don't know.
It took five extra minutes to grow a mustache.
No.
It takes me like two seconds to grow a mustache.
It's like so easy.
I didn't touch anything either.
I don't know.
My audio has been kind of weird today.
A little bit weird.
I don't know.
Do you guys notice anything different about me?
Or like anything... anything interesting about me today?
Do you notice anything like peculiar?
Something that you're like hmm... I don't remember that being there before.
Do you notice anything?
My neck is longer?
No.
More ribbons?
New hair?
No.
New contacts?
My drawing tablet?
Exactly!
And also...
Oh my gosh.
Sorry.
There's construction outside.
If you hear... I was like hoping that they would stop before.
By now I was just like clearly... surely it's later in the day.
They're not going to do any more construction.
But no.
They are doing all the construction.
And they're being so loud about it.
And so I...
Sorry.
I was waiting.
I was like waiting a little bit for it to end.
But it never did.
But look at this you guys.
Look at this.
I have a phantom hand!
It's... it's... it's not my hand.
You know how in like the Addams Family there's that little hand that like...
Does all the work?
So technically I'm not drawing today.
It's our little hand friend.
Yeah the thing!
Andricos!
Thank you!
Thank...
Whoa.
You.
Thanks.
And my hand says thank you also.
That's so creepy.
I love it.
Oh god.
What are you saying?
Oh my god!
No!
Hand!
Stop!
Hold on.
Okay.
Write something nice, hand.
Write something nice.
Like mint... M for Minto?
U.
Mmm... mud?
Mermaid!
Merm... Mird!
Oh no!
Oh my god!
No!
Stop it!
Stop it, hand!
Oh my...
Red rub!
Is the Google form submission already over?
It is.
As you can see in the pinned comment, it says that it would end two hours.
The deadline was two hours before stream.
So I'm so sorry if we didn't make it this time.
But...
Turn that frown upside down because I'll do this again someday.
Yeah.
The minty?
Um...
Okay.
Rocket R.
The minty.
Turn that frown upside down.
No.
Upside down.
The minky?
No!
Today, I'll be drawing...
You!
I'll be drawing you!
Just like that!
Well, this hand will be drawing you.
But...
I'll be drawing your profile pictures...
Um...
Uh...
Just however I want to.
Um...
I had a little Google form rather than having like...
Okay, so, okay, I'm gonna be, I'm gonna be, okay, hold on, hold on, honesty is the best policy, okay, everybody, okay, so, hold on, honest, honest ghost, I'm an honest ghost, okay, hey, I'm dragon, thank you for the 10 gifts, and thank you, um, so, usually,
like, I feel like whenever people are like, I'm gonna draw your profile pictures, this and that, whatever, it's like, you know, you donate, like, you know, you donate a, or something, and, uh, and, uh, then, um, an X, yeah, you donate, no, yeah, X on this,
X on this, um, the rotation.
And one, you're the vibe gift, and thank you, um, but, um, you know, sometimes I think, um, you know, I think that's a little sad for other people wanting to get profile pictures as well, but also, um, we're gonna change the honest ghost to, I
become an overwhelmed ghost, because sometimes, too many people send in, you know what I'm saying?
And so, then I'm like, wait, wait, there's too many, I can't, I can't do all that.
And then I have this, this compounding guilt, guilt, guilt, this is how my, my guilt, my, my guilt, because then I'm just like, oh my gosh, there's way too many!
And I get scared.
So today, I can choose as many as I want to do.
My guilt, so I can be guilt-free, because I can say, oh, I feel like doing one more today.
So, um, I get to choose, and you win.
Hold on, um, how do you, okay, hold on.
That's a hand pointing at you.
You, you win.
Thank you, thank you.
You win, thank you.
You win, because it's free.
Thank you, thank you.
Thank you.
How many souls were sacrificed for that hand?
Also, thank you so much for singing Love Deterrence yesterday.
You have no idea how long I've waited for you to sing this.
I've been jamming to it, driving to and from work for a year!
Now I can switch it with yours.
Please don't do that.
Don't do that.
I, I feel like...
We win because it's time with you.
Mint found a ghost rider?
No way.
So, how this is gonna work is I had a Google form that people would fill out and submit their usernames and, um, and, uh, a request.
Um, I might, I'll be honest, I'm probably not gonna remember what your or know what your profile picture already is, because as I see it they're like, see, this is me and my big head.
Like this.
Oh my god, there's construction.
Like that.
I look like that.
And then your profile picture on YouTube is like this.
And I'm like, Hey there.
You.
You right there.
You look like a little fly.
That's you.
So, uh, you can't see this.
I can't tell what you are.
Like what your profile...
Sometimes I can.
Sometimes it's like I'm like, oh, that's a car.
Um...
Oh, that's, that's, uh, you know, that's that VTuber or that's that character.
But other times I'm like, I can't tell.
That's a cat.
I can see the cat.
But, um, yeah, other times I can't tell at all.
Oh, you guys.
You guys.
I must tell you.
Um, but, oh.
Before I tell you, um...
But yeah, I have a whole list of people.
Uh, here.
We'll spin the great wheel.
And it will land...
You have a one in...
Uh...
I'm still scrolling.
One in...
1,354 chance...
of getting picked.
1 in...
It's better than gotcha odds, everybody!
So, um...
Yep, I'm on the screen.
That's your name!
Right there.
Maybe.
Probably.
But yeah, so, I'll pick the wheel.
I'll pick someone from the wheel.
And that way it's very... it's fair.
Um, you know.
And anybody has a chance to get a profile picture.
I put in a little thing saying like, Hey, do you have a request?
Um...
But, uh...
Nah, I'd win.
Uh, do you have a request?
And if it's just like, Draw me like one of your French ladies.
Then I can...
Potentially do that.
Wait.
Who gifted five members?
Unless that's old.
Oh yeah, that's the rotund one.
Oh, but...
Thank you for the ten gifted.
Thank you!
Sorry, I missed that one earlier.
Haha.
This game makes you feel like being a fly.
What do you mean by that?
Ma, get the camera!
You're so small.
You are.
You're very cute.
Hold on.
You're so small and you're so cute.
Ooh.
Ooh, there's your blushing.
You're like, oh my gosh, I'm so small.
See that wheel?
It's all me.
But I have a thing to tell you guys.
Let me...
Let me get it real quick first though.
Hold on.
One moment.
Oh, sorry.
That was very loud.
Even for me.
Apologies.
Oh, I forgot to say!
I forgot to greet you guys to the stream because I was so...
I was so flustered.
Thank you!
Kiss!
Using the color red to write is really tempting.
For what?
Okay.
I have something.
This is one thing to show.
So I...
Hold on.
Actually...
Can I save on both at the same time?
Oh, no!
These are all individual!
Actually, I can just screenshot it.
Screenshot.
Hold on.
I should have prepared this before stream.
Thanks for the 10 gifted!
Thank you guys so much!
Thank you!
Let's see.
Okay.
Hold on.
Here we go.
Shoo!
Okay.
I have...
More emotes!
This first batch...
is from Wealthy!
Yippee!
Hold on.
Sorry.
I gotta erase you.
There we go.
Yeah!
More emotes!
And that's not all.
I have...
Even more...
emotes!
These ones are from...
Junya!
Yeah.
I'll upload them...
after stream.
Yeah!
We have lots more emotes!
Even more...
emotes!
So...
I asked members...
what kind of emotes...
you'd be interested in.
Some people were like...
Oh!
I want a box!
I want a clown!
So...
Oh!
I want a nerd!
I want...
I want this!
I want a penlight!
Okay!
I...
Your wish is my command!
Raymak thinks of the five gifts!
So...
I cry when I fart!
Oh my gosh.
Are you okay?
Welcome to membership!
We are so back again!
Yeah.
I thought they're...
I think they're very cute.
You have a bonk!
You have a pray!
You have a wink!
You have a think!
You have a excite!
You have a drool!
You have a excite more!
You have a... Oh my god!
Did she really just say that?
This isn't all the emotes.
This is just what I got for now.
But...
Yeah!
So...
Welcome to membership!
Thank you!
Thank you guys!
I will upload these...
soon.
As goes to...
Thank you!
It's raining gifts!
Oh my god.
I know, right?
Holy moly!
Um...
Let's get started.
Ducky, thanks for the five!
Thank you!
Hold on.
I was like, why does my throat feel a little weird?
I forgot to take my medicine before.
Thank you!
Thanks for the...
Thanks for the five gifted!
Thanks for the ten gifted!
Oh my god!
Customer Johnson!
Thanks for the aqua super!
I want to say thank you for the relay karaoke yesterday.
I listened and watched the whole stream once live.
And once on VOD!
No!
You did Heaven's Abide, Sins of the Father, Love Deterrents, and Snake Eater so well.
It made me realize you have...
You can express your love for your passions uninhibited and unabashed.
Thank you!
Wait, what do you mean one out of blank?
Tee-ka!
Thanks for the gifted!
One out of question mark.
I'm scared.
Thank you!
Let's do our first person.
Uncanny scary mint emote win.
What do you mean?
I'm not scary.
I'm Moe.
Moe.
Hold on.
I don't think you can read it.
Moe!
I mean I know I'm a ghost.
But like...
I'm a cute ghost.
Because I'm amazing!
Duh!
Alright, let's pick our first victim.
Person.
I will spin the wheel.
The winner is...
Turtle!
We can't see it.
I know you won't see it until...
the name is pulled.
Because I'll be honest.
I have not vetted these.
I just copied and pasted them.
Because there were so many.
What if someone is trolling me?
And says something weird?
And then it just shows up...
on my screen.
Turtle!
Oh my gosh, I get to draw a turtle!
Hold on.
Let's see what turtle...
requested.
And there's...
Oh.
Thanks for staying true to yourself.
And being an inspiration to many.
Which includes me as well.
Two out of I don't know why I decided to go on about it.
When I have nothing else to say.
Plus I'm broke!
Please don't.
Is this me or someone else?
I don't know.
Turtle?
Did you put turtle or turtles?
But thank you customer Johnson!
Thank you!
Let's see.
Turtle...
Oh.
Wait.
Several people asked for turtles.
Oh wait.
Turtle asked for a turtle wearing sunglasses.
Wait.
Several people asked for a turtle...
wearing sunglasses.
Oh wait.
No.
Sorry.
That's just turtle.
Turtles I'm sorry.
I think this is different.
Because there's turtle and then there's turtles.
And you're turtles.
You asked for a turtle.
Turtle doesn't sound like a real word anymore.
That's not me.
I'm sorry.
So close.
You could steal it if you wanted to.
But it's gonna have sunglasses you know.
Hope you had a good day.
Because I had an interesting one.
Three black bears decided to camp my house.
And not let me leave for five hours.
Did they stand like this?
Did they stand like...
kind of all...
Bear standing emoji.
Can
I pet that dog?
No!
It's not a dog!
He has a bear standing emoji.
What are we drawing right now?
A turtle.
We're drawing a turtle with sunglasses.
I'm gonna make him really cool though.
I'm gonna make him cool.
I think I have a pinched nerve in my neck.
And I haven't been able to like...
turn my head to the side all week.
So it hurts...
to laugh.
Oh gosh.
Okay.
You would think that like...
whore whore whore.
You would think that...
being a ghost like...
you don't have to deal with so many things.
But you know what?
It was so sad when I died, and I was like, yeah, I'm a ghost!
I've escaped everything from the human shackles!
And they were like, about that.
You have everything the same, just as a ghost.
I got ghost taxes.
I've got ghost health problems.
Okay, so a turtle.
Gotta have a big ol' hump.
Like that.
Can we have the bear standing emoji in the next patch, please?
I already deleted it.
The bears get a little quirky.
It's not a bowler hat!
Because turtles have like...
Like that!
That looks like a turtle.
So far.
Sunglasses.
And he's like, yeah!
And then he's got his little legs.
But this one...
This one is giving a big ol' thumbs up.
And he has another little leg.
They have four legs.
Oh, wait.
Turtles have tails.
Why is he backwards in his shell?
What do you mean?
No, he's not.
Turtle.
Oh, he only has three legs.
You're right.
Alright.
There we go.
Let's give him an extra one just for good measure.
You know what?
I'll even color it.
Let's give him a good ol' green.
There's a turtle.
Oh my god, Squidward!
Tortellini!
Thank you for the 50k!
Thank you!
Thank you so much!
Do you think I should have made him bigger or...
Do you think it's okay?
I can make him bigger.
Give me a second.
So you can see him more easily.
You've been turted.
Isn't this... okay.
What's that saying?
They have like a long third leg or whatever?
This guy just has a long... fifth leg.
Just because he's a bit of an abomination doesn't make him... any...
Any... different.
Huh?
What do you mean, huh?
Wait.
What did I say wrong?
Why are you guys reacting like that?
You're scaring me.
The fifth leg.
Yeah, the fifth leg.
But it's actually him giving a cool thumbs up.
It's a... it's really an arm.
I gave 50 fifties five minutes ago but it didn't happen although the purchase... confirmed?
Wait, what do you mean?
50... fifties?
I saw it!
Wait, you gave even more?
As in... a big arm?
Yeah!
Are you guys seeing the vision now?
For the turtle?
And we'll give him a sandy back.
I'm still in a dream.
Cool turtle.
Sorry, I don't know how to do like professional artist things like that could probably make this go faster but I'm doing my best.
Good afternoon.
Yeah, some people brought it up but yeah, yesterday I was in the relay.
And it was so much fun.
I was so nervous.
Cause I was just like... I have like the transitions and stuff between songs.
And it was like me turning stuff on and making sure things were running properly.
And I was like...
What if I mess up a thing?
But overall it all worked out.
Even though my voice was kind of like...
There you go turtle!
Oh wait!
I must give you one more thing.
You're a little wisp turtle.
Hold on.
You're a wisp turtle.
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you.
Oh wait, I said I was gonna make it bigger.
Hold on.
So this is for your screen cap.
There you go.
He's like...
Yeah, that's one cool turtle.
That's one cool turtle.
Nice.
Alright, let's see who we get next.
Spin the wheel.
Cowabunga dudes.
Yeah.
Um...
Next is...
Damn Dan.
One thirty...
One?
L?
Damn Dan.
Damn Dan!
If you're here, raise your hand.
If not, that's okay too.
Let's see.
Also, you guys...
They have no request.
Oh my gosh.
Let's see.
Damn, Daniel!
What was I gonna say?
Oh, if you... I forgot to say.
If you entered twice, I'll be able to tell.
Because I'll be able to see that you entered twice.
Because I go into the Excel sheet that I have of your names.
And I search it.
If you entered twice...
Even if I pick you, I'm not gonna...
I'm not gonna choose you, so...
Yeah, cheaters beware.
Cheaters beware!
In case anybody was worried about that.
Welcome to membership, thank you!
Also, I saw this super chat.
Tomorrow's my birthday!
I'm going to celebrate by staying home and eating cake.
Do you think...
Do you wish me a happy birthday?
Of course, dandelion yellow!
Oh my gosh, you sent a yellow super chat just like your name!
Happy... wait.
How do I say happy...
Do I sing happy birthday?
How do I sing happy birthday as an old man?
Ha!
Happy birthday to you!
Oh gosh,
can I hit this note right now?
Happy...
Birthday!
Dear...
Dandelion yellow!
Happy birthday!
I had to work up to it.
Thanks so much!
Draw vans or scuff boats or whatever.
Anything is fine.
Okay, we can do a scuffed boat.
I like it.
I entered twice.
I hope the second would overwrite the first.
Oh!
I appreciate your honesty, Casey Raptor.
I will take that into consideration.
All right, we got scuffed boat.
Let me pull up boat real quick.
Boat to the rock.
Let's see.
Okay, this is a good picture.
Right here.
No.
This picture.
Okay.
Scuffed boat wearing vans.
I like it.
All right.
Where are my...
Okay, boat time.
Let's see.
To draw boat.
I think I'm...
Okay.
Bochy has those little hair bongles.
I'm going to give her a square head like her hair bongle, right?
One thing I really like about Bochy too is when her eyes kind of like do this.
Like that, you know?
And then...
What kind of pose should she have?
Oh, one that's like really cool, maybe.
Because she's wearing vans.
I love her hands.
Uh...
Those aren't yodas.
Those are her hands.
Right?
And...
She's got the vans.
How do I draw vans?
Hold on.
I'm not feeling it.
Cool.
We'll start...hold on.
Hmm...
Was that the Phantom of the Opera?
Yeah.
I was the Phantom...
of the Opera.
Hold on, now I need a picture of vans.
Van shoes.
Oh, we'll give her the checkered ones.
Aren't those really popular?
Oh wait, no, there's a low...
Wait, huh?
Everyone always wears those checkered vans, right?
Checkered.
No.
Hey Mint, my friend Liz is having her birthday this week.
May I have a happy birthday to give to her from you?
Sure!
Hey Liz!
I heard from your friend Cywin that it's your birthday this week!
Happy birthday!
I hope you have the bestest birthday ever and that all your dreams come true!
Ignore the...ignore the person on the screen.
Birthday!
Happy!
Happy birthday!
Happy birthday to you, Liz!
Okay.
I'm not trying to erase the birthday or anything, you know?
I'm just uh...okay.
Alright.
Bochy the Rock.
She's got...she's got her um...her big sweater on.
And uh...actually let's have her like kind of...actually I think I know an idea for a pose.
She's shrugging.
She's like...
Why...why do I exist?
And then...um...we'll give her a wide power stance.
So that she can show off the Vans.
Be like, why are you standing like that?
So you can notice my cool shoes!
And they're the checkered ones.
Uh...
Ch-ch-ch-ch-ch...
Ch -ch-ch-ch-ch-ch...
Like that.
I gotta really fill these in to sell the effect, okay?
She's wearing her Vans, everybody.
She's wearing her Vans.
Okay.
Asserting dominance.
She's shrugging.
She says, why am I alive?
Oh, she's got her little skirt on.
Oh wait, hold on.
Um...hold on.
I gotta erase her...middle.
She's gotta have her skirt on, you guys.
She's not indecent.
That'd be disgusting.
She's not walking around with no pants on, okay?
Vans called.
They want you to stop leaking their new collab that they commissioned from you.
That I didn't sign any NDA!
This is me, reacting to that.
I didn't sign any NDA.
I don't know.
I don't know what you're talking about.
This might be actually a leak of the new season.
Not gonna lie.
This might be a leak of the new season, though.
Of Bochy the Rock.
Watch like an actual Vans Bochy collab comes out.
Wait.
I got her hair color wrong.
No!
It's more light.
There we go.
Hi, Mint.
I was wondering why a cute ghost Mint kept appearing in my recommended.
Realized that my Oshie was back from the dead, kinda.
Glad to have you back, boss.
Thank you!
I'm back, baby.
I'm back.
Yeah.
Sometimes I wonder...
I'm like, do people know I'm around?
I wonder if people know that I'm here.
And then we need a blue balls.
Oh, wait.
It's more...
Aqua ball.
And a yellow ball.
Thank you.
We know.
Bochy the block.
Bochy the glock.
Bochy the rock.
Oh, wait.
Bochy the clock.
Bochy the...
Um...
The frock?
That's like a type of clothing, isn't it?
Say it?
Say what?
The smock?
The sock?
The padlock?
To continue with the birthday streak, I would be happy if you could say happy birthday to my friend...
Akus.
Did I say that right?
It's not my birthday anytime soon, but can I get a kissy kissy choo choo mwah mwah 9000?
There you go.
Mee-tee surprise.
Yeah.
There you go.
Um...
Okay.
Ah...
Akus.
Akus?
Wait.
Am I saying this right?
I can't tell.
I can't tell if I'm saying it right.
Okay.
Now we draw in her...
Oh, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Oh, here we go.
Hold on.
Oh.
One second.
There we go.
Oh, it's more like a peachy.
Hold on.
Yeah.
More like this.
Read like Akus.
Ah, okay, okay.
Happy birthday, Akus.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, dear Akus.
Happy birthday!
I hope that worked.
Meow
meow meow meow meow.
And what color is your skirt?
Gray.
I think it looks like bocce.
You guys can tell, right?
You guys can tell this is bocce, right?
You can be like, that's bocce the rock.
Or glock.
Or sock.
Yeah, it's definitely bocce.
Okay, good.
I'm actually gonna... I wonder... oh wait.
Let's see if it looks how it looks with it over the eye.
Oh yeah, I like that better.
Oh, I forgot the color in this part.
Okay, in her vans.
Now, who requested this again?
Damn, damn...
Damn, damn!
So,
um...
13...
Like that.
Perfect.
I think.
I am satisfied.
You better be.
Here, hold on.
Let me move it down a little bit.
So you don't have to crop it so weird.
Oh, wait.
There we go.
Let's move it over here.
There you go.
That's a bocce.
That's a bocce time.
Another satisfied customer.
I mean...
Are you a customer?
It was free!
The icon was free!
Yubicorn, thanks for the gift!
Thank you!
Oh, I missed some...
I'm sorry, you mentioned earlier about entering twice, but I got confused about just username or actually YouTube username.
Sorry about that.
I appreciate your honesty, Rogu.
I appreciate your honesty.
But I think...
I don't see like the ats, you know?
I only see how you appear in chat.
Unless you comment, then I see the ats, but it's usually different names.
ShaggyNerd, thanks for the gift, dude!
I was talking earlier about the karaoke yesterday.
I was so happy Maria invited me.
I was like, oh my gosh, where?
Babi's Relay.
I was like...
This is me.
When she invited me.
Even though I got the dates wrong at first because I'm an idiot and I can't read.
I was like...
That was me.
But...
It was really nice.
Everyone sounded so good.
Oh my gosh.
I was like...
Wow, everyone is...
Crazy.
Talented.
She was ball maxing.
Those eyes are really well drawn.
Thank you.
And I was like struggling what I wanted to do up until the day of.
Because I was like...
If I...
Um...
Who is this?
Sorry,
I was checking something.
Um...
I was like...
If I do a Metal Gear karaoke, I feel like people will be like...
You always do.
You always do too much Metal Gear.
I'll be like...
Sorry, I can't help it.
But also, I was like...
What if, you know, people don't know who I am.
They have to know what I'm all about, right?
Right?
What?
You don't do enough Metal Gear karaoke.
I figured also, I mean like...
The songs are still good, you know?
Like, even though it's...
Like, you don't have to know Metal Gear to enjoy the music, right?
So...
I thought it would be okay.
Alright, I'm spinning again.
So that's why I decided...
But it was fine.
It was so fun.
And I was...
I had fun like finding the photos and everything.
That I wanted to use.
The next person is....
Gingerworks!
Let's see where you are.
Where you at?
Gingerworks.
In my thing.
Yes sir, I sing Snake Eater on every karaoke.
No sir, I don't get sick of it.
Gingerworks.
Oh, they asked for an alt-mint outfit or creature-mint.
Ooh,
interesting, interesting.
Creature-mint.
Well, someone asked earlier about like a spooky one.
But I can't do a spooky one for them and also as the emote.
Let's see.
How about I just do one like really...
Okay, hold on.
How do I want to do this?
La criatura.
I must confess that I requested, but the request is very vague.
That's fine.
Some people didn't even request, so...
How do I want to do this?
Hmm...
Okay, there we go.
So crop...
Crop this.
Not very straight though.
It was a great karaoke, but can we have something other than tree frog for dinner?
I'm told chicken is good.
No!
Tree frog tastes just like chicken, don't you know?
You know, everything that's a different kind of meat tastes just like chicken.
According to the world.
Okay.
What's wrong with me?
This one needs my utmost attention.
And concentration.
Okay?
Give me one moment.
Does this even look like me anymore?
It's okay.
Once I do the hair, it will...
Thank you!
Superliminal.
Ghost made is moi.
Made of ectoplasm.
Oh, sorry.
M-O-E.
I don't see the difference.
Oh, do I need a little tongue out?
Maybe?
Now I'm reaching...
Whoops.
Redo.
Have to have that final stroke.
I didn't know what you meant by request.
So I just asked you to have a nice day.
If I get pulled, can I request in a super chat?
Of course!
You don't even have to super chat.
Remember when I said crop there?
I lied.
Because I'm coming out of your screen.
Coming out of your screen.
Open up.
Yes, Jack!
Johnny!
Oh my gosh, I think I've been calling my new cat Johnny instead of Paz lately.
She...
She is so...
smelly.
She is so stinky.
Like...
Oh my gosh.
Um...
Oh yeah, I think I said like on stream how I thought I was gonna have to take her to the vet because she was just she was just spewing poop everywhere at one point.
And...
Every time she goes to the bathroom, she just blows up the maid cafe.
It is like a...
It is just a bomb goes off.
And like...
Actually well, I was...
Um...
I was...
Cleaning and um...
I was like Oh my gosh, someone else...
I was like, oh no!
Johnny went to the bathroom again.
It smells so bad.
And then, you know who I see walk out from the litter box?
Butaro.
He was like...
I am the reigning stink champ.
And I will not let an outsider take my title.
He is the reigning champion.
So uh...
Yeah, see this looks more like me now.
Yeah,
see this looks more like me now.
Then we will do the X.
We will do that later though.
Pause.
Blow something up.
Seems in character.
Oof.
Hahaha.
But yeah.
So uh...
That's what happened.
Um... wait a second.
Oh yeah, okay.
Kinda crazy.
I think she has IBS.
Cause okay, when I first brought her home I noticed, I was like, yeah she's a little smelly.
And then like...
She would be around.
My cat would be around.
And like...
She was just farting like crazy.
And even...
And I was like, maybe she's nervous.
Because you know, she just got brought to a new home.
But even now...
She just...
She just farts all the time.
She'll... I'll pick her up and she farts.
And I...
I'll pet her and if she gets too comfortable she farts.
She's so...
She's so smelly.
Oh my god.
She's actually...
She's actually so smelly.
And like...
They never brought that up when I was like...
When I was like, hey is there anything I should know about her?
No.
They didn't say anything like, oh she's a smelly machine.
They were just like, no.
She's totally fine.
Everything's good.
And it's not like I was feeding her like new food at that point.
It was still her old food.
Um...
She just was...
Maybe it's the food itself.
Maybe...
Would you say they gaslighted you?
Okay.
Also a little bit.
Because...
When I got her, like...
They were like, oh my gosh.
You just adopted the best cat ever.
She's so sweet.
She's so nice.
She's so... Oh my gosh.
Everything about her.
She's like this wonderful purring from the other end.
Better out than in.
I always say.
Um...
But uh...
But um...
...
Her...
What the hell?
Oh god...
I...
Oh god..
Okay...
Anyway what was I saying?
Oh they were like, she's so sweet.
She's a lap cat.
She does this.
She's just the sweetest girl ever.
And I was like, Yippee!
I've always wanted a lap cat.
I was so excited.
She has not laid in my lap once.
Actually, it was maybe false advertising.
I was like, what?
Okay.
I was like, well, you know, she's still nervous.
Like, she'll get in my lap eventually.
Not even once.
She hasn't even laid in the bed with me when I'm going to sleep.
I think... I was like, why is your advertiser the ultimate lap cat?
And I mean, she's very sweet.
Don't get me wrong.
Like, she's so, so nice.
And like, she...
Maybe it was lab cat.
It's probably better, probably.
She just lays in my lap and farts the whole time.
You want her farting in your lap.
I want her... I want her...
Well, recently, if I'm on the couch, she has started like...
She has started laying next to me.
So, maybe it just takes her a little bit of extra time or something.
I don't know.
But...
But, yeah.
Now it looks like me.
Okay, what was the name by...
Gingerworks.
That's right.
Wait, what the hell?
What happened to the...
Hardness.
There we go.
Oh, I did that.
There you go.
So, hopefully...
And like, for the first time...
Last night...
She...
Did not...
Oh, I forgot the...
She did not sleep with me...
In my bed.
But she stayed in the room.
In my...
In my room.
So...
You know...
She is eventually getting there.
I think a little bit.
I forgot my eyelashes.
I forgot to have eyelashes.
Oops.
Oh, and blushing.
There you go.
I had problems with my big nasty boy when I got him.
Crazy running, jumping, etc.
Turns out the rescue just copy-pasted all cat descriptions?
Maybe I should check that out.
They were like crying though at the pet store.
They were like, they were like, oh my gosh, we're going to miss you, Paz.
Oh my god, what?
And I was like, wow, she's so beloved.
She's so sweet.
But, um, I hope that they didn't just copy and paste it.
I hope not.
Welcome to membership, thank you!
Thank you, thank you!
Anyway.
I hope not.
Okay, let's do another one.
Tears of joy to be rid of the stick you were crying because they can finally breathe.
The winner is...
Ta-da!
Venti does things!
Venti, come on down!
Make the watermelon extra round and perhaps give the cat a cowboy hat if possible.
Thank you!
Well, I don't know what your profile picture is.
So, uh, they weren't crying, their ears, their eyes weren't watering because they just cleaned her litter.
Okay, wait, we have no context for your picture.
Except that there is a watermelon and a cat.
So, hold on.
Um...
Uh...
Make the watermelon extra round and give the cat a cowboy hat if possible.
Okay.
Watermelon cat.
Watermelon cat with a hat.
What if I Google, or not Google, if I search them on YouTube.
Let's see.
If anything comes up.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Don't search their...
Oh, my God.
Don't search their username.
I didn't know that Venti was a character from Genshin Impact.
And, um...
Does things is, like, really vague.
And, like...
Oh, my God.
I didn't know.
Watermelon cat.
Let's go.
Okay.
So, we're gonna make a really round, thick watermelon.
No.
Yeah, that works.
That works.
Hmm.
Look, can you guys see me draw a heart?
Isn't that...
Oh.
Hold on, let me try to...
Let me actually, let me actually watch what I'm drawing.
Hold on.
Could you see it with my hand?
With the thing?
Okay, so the cat... we're gonna have him like sticking his head out here.
Why is drawing a circle so hard?
Yeah, you could.
He's happy to be there.
Wait.
Do you think he needs the ears or...
I feel like I'm drawing something from Battle Cats.
Nah, I like it better like this.
Actually, hold on.
There we go.
I made him a little...
A little insane.
Yeah, whatever.
Nice.
Okay, so the watermelon is really chunky.
And then a cowboy hat is like...
A tarnation.
Just like that.
Wait, how do I... Actually, I don't know what a cowboy hat looks like at all.
Cowboy...
Cowboy hat.
Okay, hold on.
Oh, yeah, yep.
Getting some fine cowboys.
I'm a cowboy.
I'm a cow...
Wait, there's cowboys, but where are the cowmen?
I'm a cowman.
Meowdy.
I don't know what the perspective is on this thing.
I guess that works.
Actually, hold on.
I'm a cowman.
That's what I be asking every day.
Hi, Maya!
I'm a cowman.
On this cowland.
Only boys in these parts.
But I'm a cowman.
I'm a lone cow...
A lone star.
Oh, we'll give him a star.
We'll give him...
We'll give him a star.
I don't know if this works.
It kind of looks more like a fedora.
But I think it will have to do.
Hi, wispss...
It looks like a fedora.
It's okay, it's okay.
I wonder if I do this.
If I have the ears sticking out, here.
I like him looking more like a potato, you know.
I kind of like that better.
All right, for the watermelon colors, we needed like a dark...
We need like a... not a neon green, like a...
That'll do.
Also, you guys, what color should the cat be?
What kind of colored cat should it be?
Howdy, m'lady.
This guy is a cow man, truly.
What color cat should it be?
Orange.
Orange cat.
I always hear that orange cats are crazy, but I had an orange cat when I was a kid, and he wasn't that crazy, actually.
Okay, those should be good colors.
How am I supposed to do this, actually?
I did not think this through.
I did not think this through at all.
Mine is... No, my orange cat was actually the most chill cat I have ever had.
He was so chill.
He was so sweet, but he did have a problem.
Like, I don't let my cats outside anymore, but when I, you know...
My family before, they didn't really care.
And... Oh, I didn't mean to zoom in.
There we go.
And...
And... But he would go to the neighbor's houses, and he would, like, walk.
He knew how to open doors.
He was a very smart cat.
Like, if the door had a handle, he would open it up.
And so, because of that, he...
He would go to the neighbor's houses and, like, let himself in.
And would just, like... The neighbors would sometimes call and be like, wait, I'm such an idiot.
Hold on.
I'm just gonna color in the whole thing, and then we'll do the other stripes.
Why am I... Work smarter, not harder, everybody.
But, um...
See, I'm stupid.
I don't know how to do this.
Um... But, yeah.
And then, um... Like, during dinner, he would just kind of sit at the table, and he wouldn't beg for food.
Like, he didn't try to climb on the table or anything.
Like, we would save him a seat at the dinner table, because you... He... Ouch, I just bit my tongue.
Oh...
I want to put my...
Oh my god.
Yeah,
he was very polite I mean, there was one time he pooped in my bed when I was sleeping.
But other than that, he was really respectful.
And he was a good guy.
Yeah, I think that's when he was going senile.
He thought my bed was a litter box.
And...
I remember like... I remember him like... trying to...
You know how when cats like... they like... scoop with their paws?
I thought he was trying to get comfy.
I was like, what are you doing little guy?
And then he turned around and just took a big ol' dupe of her.
I was like in my bed while I was...
I was like you know...
Honest mistake, truly.
Why is he wearing a snake hat?
Snake that ate an elephant.
Wait, what?
What are you talking about?
That's not very polite.
Yeah, that part was not very polite.
That part kind of sucked.
I was like, why would you...
Why would you do that?
I think he was kind of losing it.
Oh no, you guys.
I don't know if I've ever told you guys about my grandma.
But I'm gonna go see her soon.
I'm going to go see my grandma soon.
I haven't seen her in a long while.
She might not even remember me.
But...
We'll see.
I can't believe Mint just doxxed herself to be Johnny Depp.
What do you mean?
Wait, did he poop in a bed like that?
Who is this wild mustache man who replaced Mint?
What are you talking about?
I'm the mysterious traveler.
I'm a mysterious artician.
Why is it so hard making this a watermelon?
Holy cow.
I think I'm...
I think I don't know how to do anything.
Is that a seal?
No, it's a cat.
So...
Sooo...
Okay.
I got this though.
I can color it in.
I can make it nice.
I'm a simp.
The images extension can show you profile pictures.
If you have it, hover over an image.
It shows you a big version for example for users in chat.
Chat.
Isn't it more exciting to kind of get... I mean, you're not paying for it.
Take what you can get, I suppose.
Isn't it more exciting if you're like, what is she going to draw me?
That's why I asked if you wanted any requests.
Use bucket?
Will it work?
Oh.
It will work here?
It doesn't work.
Wait, hold on.
Maybe here.
Let's try again.
It doesn't work.
I can't use bucket.
It doesn't work!
I have to color it all in by hand!
I can't use bucket.
I can't.
Brush size, maybe.
No, it's okay.
You guys, calm down.
Why are you in such a rush, huh?
I like coloring in the lines.
I like it.
It's making me feel a little bit... actually too relaxed.
I should have taken a nap before this stream because I was like...
Oh no!
I'm yawning!
I am drinking coffee right now, but I'm still so sleepy.
Sleepy ghost.
Okay.
Okay, orange cat time.
Tell Amaya...
Y'all backseating artisting Picasso?
Yeah!
Stop backseating me!
Stop it!
This is the process.
It must be done by hand.
Or not at all.
Actually, I wonder if I can use bucket here.
Yippee!
I mean, it can be done by bucket sometimes.
Yay!
Oh yes, the process.
Screw the process!
A little pink nose like that.
And then...
Give this...
Give this little cow cat...
A nice...
Brown fedora.
No, this is not a fedora.
This is a cowboy hat.
What kind of fedora would be brown?
Thanks, RayMac.
There will literally be a day...
Oh!
There will literally never be a day I complain about too much Mint Metal Gear karaoke.
Ah!
I'm glad.
Sorry.
Sorry, all the donuts are backed up.
They're coming in eventually.
That was from a while ago.
Yeah...
That's okay.
I still saw it.
I'm trying to get the color.
Trying to get the perfect...
This guy is a deputy.
He is running this town.
I hope you like it.
I hope you like your...
Oh, wait!
Sorry.
I have to write your name too.
Venti does things.
But don't look that up.
Because...
Apparently, Venti is doing things.
But for the karaoke...
It's funny because I said like...
I'm not going to do karaoke.
Sorry.
I'm like tilting my head.
Venti does...
Oh, gosh.
Okay.
This is so far so good.
Oh, nice.
I was like...
Oh, I'm not going to do another karaoke for a while because I...
Because I...
My voice, my throat has not been so good.
And then I realized that the date for...
I mixed the date up for this karaoke.
I was like...
Oopsie.
What's going on?
So, but it was only 20 minutes.
And I just picked really hard songs.
You are truly an artistic genius and the cutest.
Stop!
My cat escaped from me while I was watching your stream.
And I had to take a two mile walk to get back...
Get him back home.
But I'm glad I was able to catch him and still have time for...
Is your cat okay?
Are you okay?
Sounds kind of traumatic.
Anyways, thank you, Venti.
I hope you enjoy your...
I don't know, I really like... I have so much fun doing karaoke though.
And it's like so easy if I'm just like, I don't know what I want to do today.
Karaoke, it's so easy.
Our next person is...
Reverie Bunny!
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you!
Melon, you have to leave now.
Happy Cinco de Meow-o!
Oh my gosh, it is!
Happy Cinco de Mayo, everybody.
A Catermelon?
Perry the Catermelon?
No...
Saki Saki!
Thank you for the mustache, thank you!
Reverie Bunny.
My profile pic with mint-made headband.
Scribble, scrabble.
Oh, I see you!
If you can't draw my profile picture, just draw a mochi bunny with your headband.
Thanks!
A mochi bunny!
I can do that.
Mochi bunny.
Mochi bunny, mochi bunny.
I just... it's so similar.
Thank you, thank you!
Wait.
Mochi bunny are like...
The little ones with the red eyes, right?
And then they have...
They have the green, right?
Am I thinking of the correct thing?
Yeah?
Okay, okay.
This one's actually not cursed at all.
This one's very cute, everybody.
Stream too comfy, making me want to go to...
Me too.
I'll give him a little smile though, is that okay?
Mmm, mochi.
Oh my gosh, there was like... I think it was...
I think it was...
Family Mart?
Or 7-Eleven?
That I got some so good mochi.
It was so soft.
Make him evil?
It was so soft and so delicious and...
Oh, here I'll give him a little...
Little triangle.
Itai kakushi.
And how do I want to make the headband?
Hmm...
Do I want to make it like here?
Or do I want to make it here?
Me?
Can I gotcha the alert sound?
And when the alert will show up in one dono...
Thank you!
Too bad, too bad, too bad.
Did you see... did you... oh.
I did, yes.
Yes!
I thought it was very cute.
But I don't know why you would bring up that person.
I've never talked about them before.
Oh wait, let's see.
What is that little growth coming from your head?
My hair?
This... this is hair!
You've never seen hair before?
Well that's a ribbon.
This is hair!
It's terminal.
This is hair.
The triangle?
That?
It's just what ghosts wear.
It's everywhere.
And it's terminal.
I've seen people say like it's half a cat ear.
And I kind of like that theory too.
Because I'm like dang.
I'm like so cool.
I lost half my ear.
Like I lost one of my ears.
I only have one cat ear.
What if I get a cat ear?
What if I get cat ears?
Will it look weird?
I wonder.
You're absurd.
Firefly.
Oh, six.
Oh...
Six.
OMG, Venom punished me.
I think I'm gonna do the headband.
This way.
I don't know how to do...
I'm so sorry.
I'm so sorry, Bunny.
I don't know how to do...
I don't know how to do ruffles.
That looks close enough though, right?
Looks close enough maybe.
You can kind of tell, right?
Here, I'll even do...
I'll even do the blue.
Perfecto?
You think so?
Perfecto for real?
And then I write your name.
Just needs vertical lines.
Okay.
I trust your judgment.
Wish me luck.
Gracias.
Che   dois.
A touch cake will taste the same.
To become your love.
A bread will taste the same.
A little extra cash from your bank.
Hey, I know I'm in for trouble now.
I still have in here what I want to do.
Are you good enough?
Do you want to draw me next?
Sure!
I'll draw you.
You.
Yeah, I drew that really good, right?
I know.
You.
Do you guys know that one face?
Hold on.
Okay, ignore the top.
Ignore the top text, but...
This is the only picture that I could find that wasn't a gif, okay?
So just ignore the top text.
So...
I think it's this face.
Okay, every time... Okay, you want to see me make this face?
Hold on.
Oh, my mustache.
My mustache, you look like shit.
Okay.
Don't I look the same?
I feel like my eyes are going...
Do I look the same as Shinji?
My eyes are too large?
But don't my eyes kind of look like they go in different directions?
No, it's not me that fart unleashed.
It's you.
See, there's the hand pointing.
You're a shit.
Minto get in the robot!
Lizard eyes.
It's me.
Frog eyes.
Hold on, let me see if I can blink one at a time.
Did I do it?
Am I smaller?
Why is my mustache so big now?
Hold on.
There we go.
Why is my mustache so much bigger?
Huh?
I'm Cherino?
Yes.
I am the leader.
And where's my...
Why do I feel so different?
What happened?
What happened to me?
Okay.
My hand is still here.
Alrighty.
Let's see.
Oh.
This one is for...
I'm gonna pick someone's name out of the chat.
And this one can be your profile picture.
And I'll even write your name on it.
I'm gonna open my eyes and the first name that I see will be for you.
Ready?
Three...
Two...
One...
Oh my gosh.
It's going too fast.
Oh god.
Okay.
Hold on.
One more time.
Three...
Two...
One...
I see...
Misha Gucci.
Oh.
There you go.
All yours.
Of course.
There you go.
Thanks for the super chat.
Misha Gucci.
Omedetou.
Wherever you are.
Omedetou with your toes.
Nice.
I wanna see if they come back with this as their...
As their profile picture.
I'm looking.
I'm waiting.
Best piece yet?
What do you mean by that?
I mean this was made with the most love maybe.
Oh wait.
I don't want it to be me.
Wait a second.
I should have had the...
No.
I don't want it to say fart unleashed.
It's me.
No.
Unless that's my face when my cat unleashes its fart.
Ten out of ten.
No notes.
What an honor for them.
Midcourt already made it?
No, they didn't.
They're not that fast.
Right?
Stinky.
Add a mustache to it.
That's the ugliest mustache I've ever seen.
That's a bit better.
There we go.
So mint was gaseous, snake all...
No!
It's not me.
It's not.
I'm deleting this before anybody else can take it.
The best profile picture.
Thanks for the super chat!
Next person...
is...
B!
Closing parenthesis!
The reason in particular would you be preferred...
Wait, would you prefer to be rounded up 5 foot or down to 4 foot?
It doesn't...
If something is over 5 doesn't it mean you put it at...
You put it...
to the higher number.
So 5 foot.
5 foot.
Me.
B closing parenthesis.
B...
Closing...
Oh!
Please draw yourself in the coolest, most fresh, fly, radical epic sunglasses in the world.
And a smug smile, please and thank you.
Pray emoji.
I've got you!
I've got you, I got you.
Oh, my bad.
Goodbye wheel.
Okay.
Let's see.
Me in the most cool, fly, fresh, awesome...
I can do that.
Hold on.
Look at these, though.
What?
Wrong thing.
Oh, yeah.
So close.
Hold on.
Maybe if I put them on my face when I'm looking center.
Wait, how do I get the mustache in front?
Uh-oh.
I think I just...
Oh, my gosh.
I can't move the mustache anymore.
It's stuck forever.
Wait.
Uh-oh.
Hold on.
I don't know how to get rid of the mustache.
Uh-oh.
I don't know how to move it.
Wait.
When I wanted to bring it...
I wanted it to be in front of the sunglasses.
But now...
Uh-oh.
The mustache is forever.
So close.
And so far.
If I look too far over, my head also becomes really big.
So close.
Oops.
Well, um... you guys like my glasses?
It's glued on.
I used a super glue to keep it on, you know?
Okay.
Let's draw me.
When I think of really awesome glasses...
I don't know why I'm focusing so much on this when I'm just gonna erase most of it.
Actually, I'm gonna Google.
The coolest glasses.
The coolest glasses in the world.
Oh, these are...
No!
These are terrible!
None of these are cool!
Okay, wait.
Actually...
I actually really like this one.
Okay.
This is my inspiration.
Why won't you show the picture?
Wait, hold on.
What is going on?
Hello?
Computer?
Uh... uh-oh.
Hello?
You guys, I think something's wrong with my computer.
What's going on?
Oh, there it is.
Okay, thank goodness.
Okay, okay, okay.
Okay, whew.
All right.
Let's...
All right, this is my...
This is my inspiration.
Wait!
I can just become this man.
Okay, hold on.
He's bald.
I can just take over.
Okay.
We can draw hair on him.
It's like... it's actually perfect.
It's actually perfect.
Yeah!
I'm so awesome!
I can not believe it!
I'm so cool, I'm so... I'm so cool.
Let's see.
Let's do this.
And then we'll draw my hair out here too.
Sorry, you're gonna have to crop it, but...
I believe in you.
Actually, I want my hair fluffier.
No, my hair's not that fluffy.
Oh wait, it goes in.
Never mind.
Wait.
It's fine, it's fine.
Just leave it, just leave it.
I'm being a perfectionist.
Okay.
Then let's put it... let's shade it in.
This time I'll actually use the big brush.
Guns.
Oh no!
Okay, I'm gonna have to do a slightly... slightly less white.
There we go.
I'm cosplaying Snake and Solidus at the same time.
Slightly less white.
Color.
Don't worry, I'll go back and I'll clean it up after.
I'll clean it up after.
But you're gonna have to crop it.
Sorry, I'm not...
You know.
Sometimes it... somehow it feels even balder.
What do you mean?
Oh wait, but what about...
This part?
Okay.
We'll fix it.
I'm gonna fix it.
I'm gonna fix everything.
Don't you worry.
We're gonna go in and we're gonna fix everything.
This is gonna be great.
You forgot to draw the growth?
I'm not there yet!
And it's not a growth!
I'm still just doing my hair!
So impatient.
Okay, what was I doing?
Oh, okay.
Now from here, we're gonna do this, okay?
You see?
We're gonna do that.
We're gonna...
We're gonna get all the edges.
I color outside the lines and then I fix it up.
Maybe it's more time consuming.
I don't care.
I'm just an artist here, okay?
Stop criticizing my art.
Don't criticize.
That means you hate art.
Do you hate art?
Okay, this time I'm gonna have to...
I'm getting really into this one, so I gotta...
Oh no.
I don't want you to see...
his skin.
No.
No, no, no.
Inside the lines.
Inside...
Could I have redrawn this?
Probably.
But this is for authenticity's sake, okay?
Uh-oh.
It's gonna disappear.
Is my head bigger than this man's?
Um, obviously, because I'm smarter.
This is what they wanted, you guys.
This is what they wanted.
And I feel really uncomfortable being this close to this guy's head.
I feel pretty uncomfortable right now.
I'm not gonna lie.
I'm seeing every pore.
Every... every single line in his forehead.
I'm seeing it all.
I'll never like this guy's hair.
I mean...
He's got nice skin, I'm assuming for his age, you know?
Oops.
You know what, let's not.
What the?
No, no, no.
Stop it.
I'm sorry.
This is the future the boss envisioned.
I can see his white hair.
I know.
I can see everything.
I can see everything!
Clean scalp...
Let's clean up this part right here.
Have you heard that?
No, you didn't!
You know what?
Screw it.
I don't care.
Alright, let's do...
What if I leave it this way where you can see just his...
You can see his head peeking through.
There we go.
Oh, I forgot my... Oh my gosh.
How could I forget my twin tails?
Which was the layer?
This one.
How could I forget my twin tails?
Right?
Oh my gosh, what's wrong?
I was like, something feels off.
No!
My friend Mike has his birthday tomorrow.
Are you serious?
Are you for real?
What's Mike's last name?
Tell me right now.
It's perfect.
Don't worry about it.
Hooter.
Like the store?
Like the restaurant?
I've never been to a Hooters.
I've never been to Hooters.
And people say, like, go for the wings.
But then people are also like, the wings aren't that good.
So which is it?
Which is it?
His last name is Suggma.
I don't believe you.
That's a Pokemon.
If his last name was Suggma, what...
You know how like, you know, there's like...
Last names that were...
What they did back then in the day.
Like that originated from that.
They were like, oh, I'm...
I'm...
I'm Casey Blacksmith.
You know, stuff like that.
What did they do if their last name was Suggma?
Hooters is mid?
Really?
But it's like, it feels like so exciting to think about.
Like, it's just like, wow, I'm going to Hooters.
I'm going to Hooters.
It looks just like me.
He's already got the mustache, even.
Sucking poison.
I get it.
Oh, wait.
I'll make it smaller.
There we go.
I made it smaller so that you can see it.
Perfect.
Oh, I got to write your name.
B, closing parentheses.
Wait, can I fit it on his forehead?
My handwriting is too big.
B...
Close...
Closing...
Argh!
No!
P...
Parentheses.
Po..
Pa pa...
Pa Paren...
And...
I hope you like this one.
I actually put so much effort into it.
I hope you like it.
I think I look really cool.
I think I look really awesome.
Hold on.
Don't take it just yet.
There we go.
Important part.
Now it really looks like me.
It looks so good.
Right?
Hold on.
Let me move my cursor.
There we go.
Screen cap that.
That's yours.
Be closing parenthesis.
Yeah.
She's okay I guess.
Like maybe she's amazing.
But I don't know.
Free NFT.
No!
You can't right click and save this.
You can't right click and save art.
It's my picture.
I own the pixels.
I created the pixels.
I birthed the pixels.
They are my pixels.
I own these pixels.
You cannot steal my art.
Do not right click save.
It is mine.
I paid the token.
I own the ownership.
I own it.
I have the digital certificate.
It is mine.
I just bought the NFT.
Right clicked.
Don't do that.
It's illegal.
You are literally stealing from me right now.
You are taking my artistic right.
To own this art.
Burst?
I won't right click save.
I'll just screenshot it instead.
You can't do that.
How dare you.
You do not own the actual pixels.
You do not own it.
I own every individual pixel.
I own the hex code.
You can't have these colors.
They are mine.
They are on the hex code.
If my model.
If I'm in the way.
When did my arm go up?
It's kind of freaky actually.
You can't have this.
You can not own this.
I'm even taking it back.
Be closing.
Closing parenthesis.
I'm sorry.
Mine.
Now I can right click and save.
Mint phantom.
Stop owning me.
Get owned.
I will own you.
Stop owning me.
You do not own me.
Be closing parenthesis.
This is my new identity.
I hope.
I hope they.
I don't know if they're here in the chat.
If they are.
Look at the chaos you've caused here.
Get owned.
Anyways, thank you.
I hope you like your profile picture.
Let's go to the next person.
Me no habla.
Hablo.
Isn't it habla english?
You could say she's been minted.
Why does it sound so weird like that?
Next up is...
Wimp.
No.
You're not a wimp.
Wisp.
Wispwillow!
Oh, you're very strong!
You're very strong!
Wispwillow, what's your request?
I hope it's like, don't draw me all wimpy, please.
Please draw me looking really cool.
Oh, they said none.
On your request, they said none.
My profile pic being drawn by you is already a lot.
Oh no, they wrote something really nice and I called them a wimp.
No!
I'm sorry, Wispwillow!
I'm sorry, I'll draw you looking really cool.
I'll draw you looking so awesome.
Okay, hold on.
Okay.
Since you're a wisp, we're gonna draw you as a wisp.
Oh, hold on.
I need more space.
But then...
They have beefy arms.
Like that.
Wimp no more!
Wimp no more, beefy wisp.
Beefy wisp, beefy wisp.
Beefy, beefy wisp.
Beef, beef, beef.
Like that.
Oh yeah.
Oh yeah, gigawisp.
Ghost plus fighting type.
He's ready to throw it down.
He's ready to go to town.
He's ready to not be on the ground.
He's ready to throw you on the ground.
He's ready to give a big frown.
He's ready to...
Frown?
Ground.
He's ready to make you round.
Wait, frown and round don't rhyme.
Wait.
Wait, neither do ground.
Wait, am I rhyming frown or am I rhyming...
...pound.
Wait, I said he's ready to go down.
He's ready...
Okay.
He's ready to go to town.
He's ready to...
He's ready to... give a big frown.
He's ready to... he's ready to... throw you around.
No, I did it again.
There's no D at the end.
Take the crown!
Oh, you are so good.
He's so good.
Knock you down!
Not knock you up.
He'll knock you down.
He's a beef master.
Let's see.
I wonder if I can... just fill him in.
It's a little bit more blue.
I kind of like this color.
Oh!
Sorry.
Where's the opening at?
I don't see it.
My eyes.
Wear a tasteful gown.
And
he managed to avoid being true.
Oh my god.
Can I do this?
Let's see.
Can I... No.
That's okay.
I'll do it.
I'll make it quick.
I think the color is supposed to be a little lighter blue, but that's fine.
That's fine.
Everyone's monitors are different.
It's the correct color on my monitor, you know.
Left bicep?
Yeah, this is... this is the tri tops.
This is the bi tops.
This is the ichi tops.
Honestly, only gym bros would get this, you know.
Only gym bros would be like, yo, that guy is ripped.
This guy... this guy knows what's going on.
He's so beefed up.
Yeah.
Hell yeah, wispy.
Yes!
This guy will go to your gym and he'll be like...
He'll be like...
Uh, don't film TikToks in my gym.
Today I'm gonna lift... I'm gonna lift every pound.
I'm gonna take every pound.
I'm gonna take every pound downtown.
What?
You can't write pound and town.
What's wrong with me?
Sorry.
Okay.
I keep trying to do it.
I keep trying to make it work.
It does not work.
Oh my
god.
Why is my thing so delayed?
Oh my gosh.
Thank you for the akazuba!
I cried with laughter listening to those rhymes.
Thank you, Vinto.
World's strongest... ghost...
What is that?
What's that last word?
I'm scared.
Nexy!
Thank you so much for the akadono.
Thank you.
Thank you for the akazuba.
Thank you so much.
Thank you.
This is a fart?
No!
Guys, don't be mean to him.
He's gonna beat you up.
He has the gains.
Why would you use that word?
What does it mean?
Don't call him a wimp.
Oh yeah.
He says that.
He says that actually.
You can rhyme however you want, queen.
Thank you.
Don't.
Oh, wrong letter.
Actually, it's fine.
Don't.
We use punctuation here.
Call me wimp.
Because I'm Wisp.
It's Wispwillow, right?
Let me double check.
Yes.
I'm Wispwillow.
Wisp.
Willow.
Oh yeah.
Wispwillow.
I ain't no wisp.
Wimpwillow.
I'm a wispwillow.
That's his theme song.
He comes into the ring.
Wispwillow.
Never wimpwillow.
I'm wispwillow.
Punch in my pillow.
Never say hello.
Don't call wisp me wimpwillow.
No, that's not what I said.
Shut up, Tudor.
That's not what I said.
Don't put words into my mouth.
Okay.
I hope you like that, Wispwillow.
Thank you.
Thank you for entering.
Thank you very much.
Oh my gosh.
It's already been two hours.
Holy cow.
Please wrap it up.
Why are you so mean to me?
Next up is...
Linery.
Wow.
Oh my gosh.
My chat is actually like..
I think there's something wrong with my computer today.
All the text disappeared for a second.
Linery.
Is that what you go by?
This is at.
Hi, Mai- Hi, Bijan.
Hello.
Hello, hello, hello.
Linery.
It's probably just YouTube?
I'm not sure, I'm not sure.
I think it's on YouTube then?
Maybe.
Oh, do as you please with a little heart.
So much artistic freedom.
When are you in chat?
Oh, hello!
Hello!
What do you want?
I can give you anything!
I can draw your world.
Sparkling, shimmering, wimpy.
Or if you don't want to, be wimpy, please let me know.
I can open your eyes.
Or make them close if you want to.
I can make you buff or sad.
Or even have a beard.
A whole new profile picture.
Add black glasses like yours.
Oh, okay.
Wait, to what?
To your profile?
I can't even tell what it is.
Looks like an anime girl.
Okay, I'll draw an anime girl with black glasses.
I'll make her cute.
Okay.
Good start.
Hold on, she has short hair, right?
Where'd you go?
Oh.
Yeah, she's got short hair.
Okay.
Like this short, right?
It looks pretty short.
That's ugly, sorry.
Oh gosh.
I don't know how to draw.
Why did I ever say...
Oh my god, Katsu!
Thank you for the...
50, thank you!
Thank you so much.
There we go.
And we're gonna put some cool black glasses on.
Wait, I think it's running into their little smile.
Oh.
Whoa, whoa.
Looks like Velma.
Drinkies!
Ahem.
Jankies.
Um...
They're gonna be waving.
Like...
Hello.
Hi.
Okay, they're either waving...
Or they're saying...
Give me five dollars.
Oh, sorry.
I forgot to do the glasses.
Okay, hold on.
That's four?
Oh, you're right.
Give me four dollars.
You know, that's better because that's a spooky number.
That's what I meant to point.
As a ghost, I can only count up to four.
Because anything beyond five doesn't really matter.
I think beyond four doesn't matter at all.
Because only five dollars matter.
I mean, no, only four dollars matter.
Give me four dollars!
Let's see... she's got a little bit of a blush here.
The hair color that your profile picture has is kind of an ashy...
It's like a yellowy grayish color.
Maybe...
Yeah, I like that.
Perfect.
Oh my gosh.
Thanks for the four dollars!
Thank you!
Stop.
Okay, it's okay.
You guys can stop now.
The bit's over.
The bit's done.
We've left the bit.
We've abandoned the bit.
The bit is done.
The bit is over.
We are moving on to the next thing.
Thank you!
Beige?
I guess it's kind of beige, right?
I guess beige is a better way to put it.
But it's like... when you go to the hair salon...
This hair color is like very popular.
Like, Mumei's hair color is extremely popular in Japan right now.
And it's like a dusty brown is how they describe it.
And dusty colors right now are like extremely popular.
Like dusty pink...
Anything dusty.
And they mean it in like a good way.
Kind of looks like Yuno from Hidamari Sketch.
Really?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
It's like ash.
Yeah, yeah.
They say ashy.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
They don't say dusty.
They say ashy.
Thank you.
Yeah, yeah.
They say like ashy brown.
What was I going to say?
Kotori hair.
Yes, yes, yes, yes.
My... What was I going to say?
Oh my gosh.
Oh, my friend.
When she went to... When I met with her last...
She had gotten... She had gotten her hair done and...
I was like, oh my gosh, I love the color because she...
The color was that... was that ashy brown.
I was like, oh my gosh, it looks so good.
I've kind of considered it before.
It's just so cute.
Stop dissing Mumu.
What do you mean?
I'm not dissing her at all.
I'm saying the color is nice.
What do you mean I'm dissing her?
I like the color.
What are you talking about?
Okay.
This was... Oh.
Let me write your name.
Wait, hold on.
Let me make that E nicer.
Thank you, Linerie.
Thank you.
Thank you, thank you.
It's funny how Mumei's ponytail is longer than some people are tall.
Wait, how long is her ponytail?
Her last name is Nanashi, right?
Yeah.
Mumei Nanashi.
Oh my god.
Wow.
It's so fluffy.
It's so long.
It's not past her feet.
It's like to her... the middle of her...
calves.
It's still pretty long though.
No name.
Nice.
Okay.
Alrighty.
Oh wait.
Let me make this bigger for you.
For when you screenshot it.
I'm so sorry.
I should have...
I should have done that.
Hold on.
Let me make this bigger for you.
For when you screenshot it.
There you go.
Linerie.
Thank you.
You're welcome.
I hope it's what you wanted.
I hope... I hope it was good enough.
Hopefully.
Okay.
Next person.
Oh, one second.
Okay.
It could be you.
It's you.
It's you, Cashews.
Cashews.
It's you.
Cashews, if you're here, please stand up.
Please stand up.
It's me.
It's not you.
You're Raymac.
You're not Cashews.
I love gamble.
Yeah, but it's free.
It's free gamble.
Okay.
I'm going to get rid of these sunglasses now.
As really awesome as I look.
Cashews.
My favorite nut.
My favorite nut?
Okay.
My favorite nut is...
Why did I almost just say raspberries?
Um...
Um, no.
It's a...
Maybe mine is actually Cashews.
They asked for Doman Cashew from G Gundam.
But it's just his hair and clothes on a cashew nut.
Doman Cashew.
Okay.
I have to look this guy up.
Oh, Wait, there's a cashew n the chat.
You're... wait.
This is just like with Turtles.
And turtle.
How does...
How is this happening?
More than.
More than once.
What?
If I looked up just Cashew...
Oh my gosh.
Oh, wait.
Oh, no.
I don't see you.
There's just cashews.
Cashew.
Did you not submit...
Oh my gosh, turtle!
I like your profile picture.
Cashews and cashew are both in chat.
Oh, there's... wait, I didn't enter.
I need to keep my picture for branding.
Branding.
I understand.
That's okay.
I get it.
It could have been you.
I'm not good enough for your brand, huh?
Thank you, thank you.
Four dollars.
No more, no less.
Thank you!
Very true.
And I get to keep all of that.
Because if it was YouTube, they'd take 30%.
But I get to keep that.
Cashews are actually related to poison ivy and can't be touched with your bare hands.
Really?
I'm always so scared.
What if one day I get an almond that devolved and I eat it and it's poisonous?
You know what I mean?
What if it returns to being an evil almond?
And I eat it and I die?
What if it genetically regresses?
And then I... I mean, I'm already dead, but like...
I worry for you guys.
Wait, really?
What do you mean, really?
Did you not know that about almonds?
Is Streamlab still blocked for you or are they paying you now?
I haven't...
I haven't received any money since I...
Well, like, it's...
It's all trapped in PayPal.
And then YouTube hasn't paid me.
So I haven't received any...
I haven't received anything.
But it's okay.
I'm alright.
I still paid rent.
I'm okay.
This sounds fake.
What are you talking about?
No almonds...
Almonds used to be poisonous.
It's true.
Yeah, it's just in PayPal jail because...
Well, I'm really lucky I can use PayPal because...
What happened before I graduated was...
They marked me as suspicious.
And I...
And they were like...
You can never use PayPal again.
You can never open another PayPal again in your life.
You can never even smell.
You can never look.
You don't even glance in our direction.
PayPal hates you now.
You are on the hit list.
You are...
You are forever banned.
For the silly drawings.
Ah, thanks!
And so...
I had to come up with another way to get the Streamlabs donations.
And...
That was three years ago.
Yeah, it was three years ago that happened.
But...
I figured...
I have...
Worked around it...
To the best of my ability.
So...
Yeah...
It was complicated.
So it's still a problem.
Kind of.
But it's okay.
I...
I hear that happens all the time...
Or not all the time...
But...
More often than it should.
Where it's like...
I see...
Like...
Artists who will be like...
My PayPal got...
Banned forever.
And I can't do anything about it.
So...
PayPal is kind of...
Icky.
Can't you contact their customer support?
Oh, yeah.
I definitely tried.
And...
They were like...
Sorry.
We literally can't do anything.
I was like...
Oh...
Okay.
Thanks.
For nothing.
So...
Yeah.
It's fine though.
It's fine.
Things are fine.
It's just the issue...
I think...
I think when I went to heaven...
I was very excited.
Because I was like...
Oh my gosh.
I don't have to deal with PayPal anymore.
I don't like...
I was like, oh my gosh, I never have to deal with them anymore!
This is so awesome!
And then when I came back, I was like...
The troubles of being indie.
But I was like, oh man...
It's funny, I was talking to...
I was talking to...
Matara last night.
And like...
With the relay, I was just like...
Man, it was so awesome seeing...
Because I tried to watch mostly everybody.
But I had some stuff to do later on in the night.
It was so fun seeing...
Everybody cheering on their...
How do I say?
Their genmates, I guess?
They were just like...
Woohoo!
The...
I'm from...
Idol!
And this person is also from Idol!
Let's go!
You know, stuff like that.
So I was just like...
Man...
I kind of...
I'm like...
I don't know...
I was telling her...
I was just like...
I feel kind of lonely.
I have no camaraderie with people anymore.
And I was just like...
I wish...
I could have become...
I wish I could have come back...
Or become indie with like...
With a group of people.
Or something.
So that...
We could like...
Stick together.
And she was just like...
She was like...
Wow!
You know...
Like...
She was actually kind of surprised.
But I was like...
I don't know.
I just kind of miss having like the...
Camaraderie.
But it was...
That's why I told her...
I was like...
I'm really grateful that she...
Is inviting me to so many collabs.
Because I'm just...
I'm just kind of like lonely.
I'm just kind of like lonely a little bit.
She was just like...
If there is anybody that I know...
That like...
You know...
You want to collab with...
Just let me know.
And I'll...
I'll...
Get you in contact with them.
So she's been helping out a lot.
And you know...
I'm really grateful that she like...
Has been organizing the collabs with...
With...
With me and stuff.
So...
But yeah...
It's been like...
Not bothering me.
But it's just...
You know...
Kind of...
Something that's...
Been on my mind a little bit.
And stuff.
And then I'm...
You know...
I'm kind of like...
Kind of shy.
So I don't reach out to people.
So it's kind of also my fault.
But I should...
Reach out to people.
Since I'm...
Sad and lonely.
But yeah...
It's okay.
Did I pull another person?
Oh my god.
Cassius is over here being like...
Uh...
Hello?
Um...
Can I get my...
My...
My Gundam...
Drawing?
Please?
Let me google them.
Oh!
This guy!
This guy is so awesome!
Um...
Okay.
Hold on.
What outfit though?
Um...
Uh huh.
Hell yeah, he is.
Yeah!
Speaking of cassius, my neighbor has a cashew tree and my fridge is full of them.
Cashew juice is super- I'm so jealous because cusses are so expensive.
Nice!
I believe mint can make friends despite her smell.
What do you mean, despite my smell?
I'm so minty fresh!
It's not me.
I can see that smelly.
He has multiple?
Oh my god, I see your profile picture.
Okay, hold on.
Like, I see this one.
But I think your profile picture...
This one is from Dynasty Warriors though.
I think your profile picture seems to be his normal outfit.
Okay, so there's this one.
And then there's...
I don't want to cosplay.
This one?
It's so tiny, why is it so small?
I can't see it.
This one?
This one but with the red cape.
Which do you want?
Excuse me, spiky bread coming through.
No!
Stop, it hurts!
That's his Gundam fighter suit.
That one is good enough.
Which one?
I posted both.
I'll just do the one on the left maybe.
Because I think that's what he's wearing in your profile picture.
In my mind, you smell like Baja Blast and not mint.
I don't even know what that smells like.
But I'm assuming it's fruity, right?
That one.
Yeah, that one.
I pick that one.
Pick number three, my lord.
Okay, I'm gonna have this on the screen though.
Wait, there we go.
Okay, put that right over there.
And...
It's chemical-y?
Oh, they said left.
Oh, okay, thank you.
Oh!
Thank you, thank you.
This hand of mine glows with an awesome power.
It's burning grip tells me to defeat you.
It makes sense if you watch G Gundam.
Thanks, Virulent.
Okay, I now need to find a picture of Akashu.
What?
I think I'm gonna be sick.
This is what cashews look like?
From the tree?
I realize I've never seen a cashew on a tree before.
And it's hideous.
It's disgusting!
What is this?
Oh my god, it looks like a little worm coming out!
Oh my god!
Oh my god, it's awful.
Look at this!
Oh my god!
What?
What is this?
It looks so gross!
It's like an apple with a worm coming out!
Wow!
I've never seen a cashew tree before!
Oh no!
Oh my god, these are so gross!
No!
Wait, the cashew nut is not the top part?
Wait.
Where's the cashew nut?
It's the top part, right?
Don't seed shame it.
Where do you...
Where's the cashew nut?
Is it inside here?
Inside this part?
Or...
Because this looks like it's cut open.
And there's no cashew nut here.
Mint ruined cashews for herself.
Wait, what does an almond look like?
Almond.
Oh, see this one looks like a nut.
This one looks so normal.
This one looks...
It's kind of fuzzy.
Looks normal.
Normal nut.
Nothing...
No big deal.
Normal nut.
NBD, NBD.
Zucchini is actually prettier when you see it.
Zucchini...
Can't zucchinis have flowers on them?
Or am I lying?
Oh, I want some zucchini now.
I'm kind of hungry.
Oh my gosh, I just...
I just realized I haven't had dinner.
I can do a few more.
Zucchinis look normal.
Normal nut, normal nut.
Okay, let me find a cashew.
Cashew nut.
Oh my god.
It's so gross.
It's so nasty.
Sorry, cashew.
I'm not calling you nasty.
I'm calling your baby pictures nasty.
Why can't I find just a singular nut?
Cashew nut.
Okay, perfect.
Alright, now we're gonna draw him onto this nut.
Why is it glistening?
It's oily.
Cashews have oil on them.
A little bit at least, don't they?
It's like a cashew oil.
Okay, let's start with his hair.
Wait.
This is so anime.
This is what I feel like I drew as a kid.
Like this kind of hairstyle.
This is like the hairstyle I drew as a kid.
When I was like, oh I'm gonna be an anime artist.
Anime nut, anime nut, anime nut.
More likely than you think.
We're gonna cover up his little pooper right there.
Right there, okay.
Indecent, indecent, indecent, indecent.
Whoops.
Oh, oh he's back.
Okay.
It's a nut, it's a nut, it's a nut, it's a nut.
It's a nut.
Oh, hi Hana!
It's a nut, it's a nut.
It's a nut.
It's a...
What's a nut with you!
Oh man, I'm the best at jokes.
I'm so good at jokes you guys.
Not much.
How about you guys?
How about you?
Nacho cheese!
Busting a nut!
No!
Save the nuts!
Don't beat them up.
Don't bust them up.
Bust a move instead of busting a nut.
Oh my gosh, I knew you guys would love it.
I knew you guys would love it.
Oh no, it looks too awesome.
It looks just like him, doesn't it?
It honestly looks so good.
It kind of feels like him.
You know how making visual novels of pigeons and weird characters.
Like the KFC one.
Busting a nut.
Mint Fantomo.
Stop my name!
Like...
Yeah, like the...
What's the word?
The KFC one.
I feel like there would be one about nuts and cash.
This is Kashukun.
Or KFC.
You know?
And their catchphrase is like, Nothing wrong about it.
Dating a nut.
Nothing wrong about it.
Nothing wrong
about it.
Noo!
Noooo!
Pics that go hard.
This might be my magnum opus of profile pictures.
I don't know if I can do another one after this one.
It's too good.
Okay, I'm normal.
I'm normal.
I'm not normal.
I'm thinking about my nut husband.
People would be actually discussing, like, who's the hottest nut.
Be like, oh my gosh.
There's something so sexy about how brooding... how brooding Pistachio is.
They'd be like, he's so kakui.
Wow.
Wait, this doesn't look right.
Hold on.
Okay, let's... I'm just gonna draw this for now.
And the other opening.
I'm only gonna give the jacket.
No pants.
This guy is too sexy for pants.
Kinda like that.
She's normal.
I'm normal.
I can't... I can't draw a perspective.
I'm so sorry.
Like, I'm trying to follow the art... the picture itself, but...
I think my perspective is wrong.
I need to go back to art school.
Like I totally ever went before.
Your magna opus.
Yo, this PFP is packing.
That's what I'm saying.
It's really good.
And he's gotta get his shirt on.
He's got his little shirt.
His little green shirt.
And
then...
I'll do the belt down here.
There we go.
And then...
200k!
We did it!
Let's go!
Let's not...
Let's not go!
Bust a nut!
Let's go!
Thank you guys!
Thank you for 200k!
Thank you!
Thank you guys so much!
Oh gosh.
My chat is... Oh, fake me!
Oh my gosh.
Thank you for the...
Thank you so much!
Thank you!
Oh my gosh.
Thank you so much.
Please.
It's okay.
Thank you so much!
Ignore this part right here, okay?
Ignore that.
This is how you get 200k subs.
200k!
Thank you!
Oh my gosh.
Brick, thank you for the 50!
Wait, my chat is really... really delayed.
I have to do something for...
I still have to do something for...
Well, I have to think of something to do for 200k.
Oh gosh.
Thank you guys so much!
Thank you!
Thank you so much!
200k!
Wow!
We'll do something... Oh gosh, wait.
Do I have to readjust my schedule for next week then?
I might have to.
I didn't have anything planned.
Uh oh.
Okay, I might have to move some stuff around.
What should I do?
Bustin' out to 200k!
Woo!
Let's go!
I have to think of something to do.
I don't want to just do a karaoke.
Congratulations!
Arigato!
Uwa!
Pyrobug, thanks for the akasubo!
Oh my gosh, my chat is so...
I have to like, read chat through OBS.
It is so broken on the computer.
It is so broken.
But thank you, I'm hoping I'm seeing the messages.
I'm hoping.
If I'm a little slow, it's because of...
It's because of...
It's because YouTube chat on...
On...
Browser is breaking.
Thank you!
Wait.
Hold on.
I couldn't...
I couldn't read it.
It was too small.
It'll...
It'll appear eventually.
In browser.
Nut tier list?
No!
This isn't a very pretty color.
I'm gonna make it more yellow.
Oh, there it is!
Oh, thank you for the big akadono!
Congrats on busting over 200k!
Thank you!
Thank you guys!
Thank you so much!
Thank you!
There we go.
There we go!
That should be good for your profile picture, right?
Cashews, here you are!
Oh, wait.
Let me write your name.
Wait.
Was it cashews or cashew?
Cashews.
Julian, thanks for the vibe gifted!
Thank you for the...
Thank you!
Oh my gosh.
Thank you for all the super chats!
It is so delayed.
I'm so sorry.
Oh yeah.
Wait.
I'm trying to draw it along as luscious curves.
There we go.
There you go, cashews!
I think this one is my best one yet.
Maybe.
Sorry that the color is a little weird.
Just ignore it.
Nobody will sell.
Nobody will see it.
It'll be too small.
Congrats on 200k!
Thank you!
Thank you guys!
Crooked Matter, thanks for the vibe gifted!
Oh, gifted!
Thank you!
Thank you guys!
Oath, Warm, Jeb!
Thank you!
Do you think you'd consider doing mid-day Minecraft and miss listening to it at work?
I definitely want to.
I just want to be in a server, maybe.
I can still probably be on a... on a private... private thing.
Mike, thanks for the 100!
Thank you for the  !
Congrats on 200k!
You spooky ghost!
Thank you!
Thank you so much!
Oh my gosh.
Thank you guys!
It really is the best one.
I think this one is my best one.
Oh my gosh, PhD killers!
Thanks for 6 months membership!
To a hundred thousand, oh my god!
6 months ago!
I was not!
I was at like 10k!
Now I'm back.
And I just hit 200k!
Crazy.
Crazy, crazy, crazy.
Oh, one block!
I do like one block.
No!
Thank you!
200k, let's go bust a nut!
Marilyn, thank you for the 5 gifted!
Misakuchi!
Thank you for the 10!
I love your profile picture!
Oh my gosh...
Here's to 300k next, I'll do my best.
I'll do my best to be entertaining enough for 300k!
Alright, Cashews, I hope you screencapped it.
Cha-chow!
I'll do 2 more.
1 million before the end of the year?
Actually impossible, but thank you for your high hopes.
Yuki!
Thanks for the 20 gifted!
Thank you!
Oh my god, the claps are for me!
The claps are for me!
Next person is...
Alaric!
Alaric, if you're here, congratulations!
Congratulations!
Oh, wait, wait, wait.
Undo?
Uh...
Oh, wait.
Uh-oh.
You entered twice!
Alaric...
Wait, what?
No.
Alaric, you entered twice!
What is this?
I'm kinda scared.
You sent a picture.
Or a link to a picture.
Alaric, you entered twice!
Why did you enter twice?
You asked for the same thing both times!
I saw you were in chat.
What do you have to say for yourself?
Shame him.
I am.
What do you have to...
What do you have to say for yourself?
This is like...
I kinda wanna draw this, though.
Which is why I'm...
Where did you go?
I can't tell if you've...
I didn't mean to?
What do you mean you didn't mean to?
What do you mean?
Okay.
Because you entered twice.
I will...
I will still do it.
But I will set a timer.
Where I only have...
One minute to draw it.
And the thing you asked me to draw is...
But...
Peculiar things are the gifted.
Oh my god, I don't want this person's butt on my screen so large.
What is the context of this photo?
Actually, I don't want to know.
I don't even know what this is.
But I'm going to give myself one minute.
To draw this.
And starting now.
Time.
Just boys being boys.
Congrats on 200k!
Thank you!
This is the horse.
By the way.
The one right here.
That's that guy.
That's the horse.
What's up!
Thanks for the five gifted.
Thank you so much!
I think I actually got it pretty well.
I think I got it pretty well actually.
Let me write your name.
It's less of a profile pic because it's kind of more portrait style.
But I did my best.
Sorry.
I'm not going to color it in.
Because I sped running.
I call this one Metal Gear.
Yeah, everybody's watching.
They're enjoying.
I think this one's pretty good.
Oh, hold on.
I did forget this one.
That's it!
There's his other arm.
He's giving him a head pat.
He's giving him a head pat obviously.
There we go.
Stretch.
Okay.
This belongs in a museum.
It belongs in a museum.
Thank you, Indy.
Okay.
Next one.
Which might be the last one.
We'll see how in depth it is.
We'll see.
Congratulations to Manthy Rose.
Manthy Rose.
If you're here.
Let's see what you've got.
Whoa.
Oh my gosh.
My preview of my stream.
There's a little preview for YouTube.
It showed me just getting rid of the Gundam guy.
That's crazy.
A Wisp version of my OC in the profile pic.
Manthy, I sure hope you're here.
I sure hope you're here, Manthy.
Because...
Raiders?
Oh, hello.
Thanks for the raid.
Hello, hello.
Whoever raided me, thank you.
Sorry, my chat's a little broken right now.
I can't...
I can't see.
Oh, he's here?
I'm here!
Oh my gosh.
Wait.
Hold on.
Where are you?
I'm looking.
Don't worry, guys.
I will be doing this again.
I hope you guys like this style.
I just feel like it's...
Like I said, it's less overwhelming for me.
And also gives other people a shot.
Even though I appreciate every single one of you and everybody who...
I never win.
Yippee!
See?
I just...
I want everybody to have a chance.
So...
Manthy, I can't tell what your...
Wait.
Manthy, can you post your profile picture under the MintoLive hashtag?
And I'll just get it from there.
Oh, it looks like a Vtuber.
Ah!
Here I am!
I see you!
Kind of.
My chat is so slow.
I don't know what's going on.
I think it's YouTube.
Maybe I should refresh.
Refresh.
There you are.
I'm gonna go check my hashtag.
W2taxmore picture the five gifted!
Sorry if I...
Sorry if I missed it earlier.
Chat was being so icky.
I can't read anything.
I'm looking at everything that's in the file.
The live tag and it's so cursed.
Oh my gosh.
We aren't icky.
Oh, I think it's fixed now.
I think it's fixed.
I think it's fixed now.
So Maple, why did you... Oh, I see it.
Oh, there it is.
Thank you.
Oh, they're so pretty.
Is it okay if I... I'm just gonna... I'm gonna put it on the screen.
I hope that's okay.
So that I can have a reference.
Easy to see reference.
Maple, why did you draw?
Why did you draw yourself as... as... with a... with a...
You made me.
Thanks for the raid.
Thank you.
Thank you so much.
Hello.
Hello everybody.
Oh, he lost one ear.
Alright.
Why are there so many people raiding me?
What's going on?
Thank you for the raid.
Hello.
What is going on?
Why are there so many people raiding me?
What's happening?
I'm in my popular fires.
What?
Okay, there we go.
Big and bulbous.
For anybody coming in, I'm drawing profile pictures.
Nothing too fancy.
We're just kind of chit-chatting.
We're just hanging out.
Hey, I'm Dragon.
Thanks for the 10 gift tips.
Hey, don't try.
Thank you guys.
Thank you.
Thank you so much.
Oh, perfect.
Okay.
First, we'll start off with our cat.
Our wisp.
And then you got a little hat, so I definitely want to draw that.
Oh, and the hair ribbon too.
I'll draw the hair ribbon.
It does kind of look like a toho.
Art by Mint.
That's me.
That's my name.
My name's Mint.
I'm Minto.
That's my name.
Don't wear it out.
And the hat.
I'm so concentrated.
Okay.
All right.
Very good.
Amazing artwork there.
Stop it.
You're just trying to flatter me.
You're just trying to make me feel good.
Bustin'.
Bustin' makes me feel good.
Oh, wait.
I was like, why is it acting weird?
There we go.
Perfect.
Look at this cute little guy.
He's so precious.
He's so innocent.
Never a bad thought.
Only good thoughts.
Oh, wait.
This is the ears.
Only good thoughts.
Never bad thoughts.
Never weird thoughts.
Wisps are good and don't have weird thoughts.
Welcome to membership.
Thank you so much.
Yeah, you're normal.
You're normal.
You're so normal.
You're totally normal.
Right, chat?
You're normal.
What was that voice that came out of me?
I think I am a demon sometimes.
And the...
I'm gonna make the heart blue.
Blue, blue, blue.
And the ribbon, too.
Blue.
Double D, double I.
I'm blue.
I'm starting to get really hungry, so it's hard for me to think.
So I apologize...
for any brain cells lacking in this moment.
Your art is very amazing and unique and I love it.
Thank you, Vin.
Really?
Well, you don't have to be so nice.
Come on.
I think... I think when someone is just like, your art is...
unique.
Usually it's like, not a compliment.
But I appreciate it.
Thank you.
Yeah, your art is...
It's unique.
It's...
unconventional.
You know, let's...
I call it bold and brash.
Picasso moment, for real.
Picasso real.
Mint Casso.
I'm not the Minky.
I'm Mint Casso.
That's me.
Mint Casso.
Casso.
Tenginmin let us be nice to you...
No.
I don't accept compliments.
Um, I'm gonna...
It doesn't have... Usually... I'm gonna give it...
I'm gonna give it the front hair.
A little bit.
Kinda like a little bit of fringe.
Cute!
And a ponytail.
Maybe not the ponytail.
Kind of looks like your uncle's rat tail.
Looks like your uncle's rat tail a little bit.
There we go.
There we go, I think.
Perhaps that is... good.
Speaking from experience...
I don't know if my... actually I think one of... I have several uncles.
I think one of them had a rat tail.
Yeah.
Because a couple of my uncles were in a biker gang, so...
I think one of them had a rat tail.
When he was in the gang.
Okay, let me write your name.
Manthy Rose.
And your QOC.
And... I'm sorry, I'm going to delete your OC.
Goodbye.
There you go.
Grandma's side of the family, maybe?
No!
The other side of the family.
Hahaha.
The other side.
Yeah.
Your render of the sack of Rome will be my new profile picture.
Thank you, queen.
Thank you.
Thank you for this.
Thank you for turning this weird detective into a cute little wisp.
I love this so much.
Thank you!
Is your uncle Ghost Rider?
Yeah, actually.
Oh yes, the sack of Rome.
I recall the head pat.
Thank you, Manthy.
I hope you saved it.
If not, get it in the VOD.
Alrighty.
And...
Let's do one last one.
Mint is my sack of the Roman Empire.
What does that mean?
What is the sack of the Roman Empire?
Oh!
Hahaha.
Our winner is...
Sideways!
Hahaha.
Congrats!
What did you ask for?
Hahaha.
Let's go!
Nothing specifically.
But have fun with it.
Love you, Minto!
While you are here, I saw you...
Is there anything you actually want?
Hahaha.
Do you often think about the Roman Empire, Mint?
I honestly think about the Romans a lot...
I think about the Roman Empire...
I think you can't say you're Roman Empire anymore, because people are always thinking about the Roman Empire now, because they're always talking saying this is my Roman Empire.
Can I have a red 2002 Mazda Miata with your ribbon on it?
I got you.
Not the Miata.
Okay.
This is the one, right?
To whoever's car this is, thank you for allowing me to use it for my commercial use.
Actually, I'm gonna make it a little bit smaller so that you can screenshot it more easily.
Okay, so first...
There we go.
Alright.
We're gonna...
We're gonna do this.
We're gonna put me on the car.
We're gonna wrap me on...
Actually, maybe I should be the other way.
Gonna put...
Yeah, Itasha time, baby.
We're gonna put me on the car.
Yeah, it's gonna be...
Actually...
No, it doesn't have to be sideways.
It can just be...
Multiple of me.
It can be many of me.
Multiple...
Multiple Minto.
Okay, hold on.
I do have to do this though.
Gotta pimp that rod.
Yeah.
Actually, for this one, we'll have one here.
Hold on, I'm gonna make it transparent first.
And then we'll have this one here.
But flipped.
That scared me.
Oh.
There we go.
Nice.
Okay.
So, 4 Minto on a car.
4 Minto on a car.
Just like this.
Okay, now we erase.
Which is the first Minto?
Wait, which is the original?
Okay.
You're not the original, but we'll take it.
So, the reason we're...
Minto sisters?
Are they single?
Asking for a... Frened.
I think Frened should have enough courage to ask for themselves.
Just saying.
I'm actually considering doing them, by the way.
Kinda sorta abandoned my old project that a Miata is smaller and cheaper.
Don't worry, I haven't forgotten the headband.
But why red on it?
I'm not red at all.
I wouldn't match.
Red for the rage inside you.
Actually, hold on.
I'm gonna take a picture just for this.
Just for this Itasha.
Okay.
Save image.
Now the red will match.
Sorry if it's not flushed, by the way.
I'm doing my best.
My minto besto.
Ganba minto.
Oh, not that one.
Is it this one?
Yup.
Wait, I messed up.
Okay, hold on.
These need to be more... hmm.
How do I do this?
Right now, they're kind of conjoined twins.
That's okay.
One can be higher and one can be...
Oh, like that.
Like that.
One can be higher and one can be lower.
Just like that.
Oh, wait.
Wrong one.
This one.
There we go.
If anybody... I mean...
I don't expect anybody to ever make an Itasha out of me.
But it would be very cool to see.
I love...
Um...
Seeing Itasha.
So...
You know.
Not that I'm expecting it or anything.
I'm just saying.
If you decide to... If you're like, I want to make an Itasha or someone.
Uh...
A certain...
A certain ghost maid would be super enthused about the idea.
I'm just saying.
Someone of my...
Of me.
My...
Um...
My personality would be very excited.
It's just the hood for this one, by the way.
It's just the hood.
I see.
Uh...
Why can't I get this?
Why is it going so...
Why is it like so janky?
Why is it so lumpy?
What's going on?
What's happening?
Stop!
Okay.
Oh my gosh.
Eraser too big?
I don't think it's the eraser's fault.
It's like...
When I do it, it's...
First of all, it's like...
Look at that.
Look at the size of the eraser.
But that's all it does.
It's that tiny amount.
And then, I think it's like...
Not...
It's like making it not very smooth.
Oh, smoothing is off.
That's why.
Maybe I just needed smoothing on a little bit more.
But it's hard to tell where...
Hmm.
Wee!
Help me!
Please!
I'm doing my best.
No one will notice.
Your profile picture will be too small.
Okay.
That's one.
Sorry.
I'm like so focused on this.
I'm barely reading chat.
Oh, wait.
Now, the smoothing is at a hundred.
No, no.
I turned it off.
So, I can do this quickly.
Okay.
There we go.
Next.
Okay.
Next is this one.
Is it this one?
No.
This one.
Okay.
Let's get rid of the body.
Yadda yadda yadda.
Get rid of the bodies.
Hide the bodies.
Dispose of the bodies.
Oh, what happened to my body?
I don't know actually.
Kind of freaky.
I wonder who's next.
Congrats on 200k!
Thank you!
Thank you so much!
Thank you, thank you, thank you!
Dispose of the bodies!
Hide the bodies!
Get rid of the bodies!
We won't be caught today!
I'm not doing time!
Not for this crime!
We'll hide the bodies away!
And see the sun the next day!
Okay.
That one wasn't so bad.
Oh my god!
Wait.
Whatever.
Are you guys seeing the vision?
First of all though, I have to...
I have to erase my forehead here.
Goodbye forehead.
Alright, last but not least.
This one.
I can totally see the vision.
You can?
I'm a split head now.
Hole in the head.
Head empty.
If you look inside...
If you peer inside my mind...
You will see.
Gas, gas, gas.
That's all that's going on in there.
Alright.
It might be a little bit messy.
But uh...
I just don't have steady hands.
Okay.
Good enough.
Oh no!
I forgot the body on the other one!
We didn't finish hiding the body!
We're terrible criminals.
We're so bad at this.
Frank, welcome to membership.
Thank you very much.
Thank you.
I appreciate it.
Very good.
Sideways, what do you think so far?
Rate my Itasha skills out of 10?
Oh, but did you think I was done?
Because...
What would this car be without?
One more Minto!
But this time...
Vito!
More.
One more.
Oh, I have to also...
One more Minto.
Enhance.
Okay.
Very good.
She knows what the people want!
I don't know if Sideways is a feet guy.
Feet person.
I have no idea.
But I think because you can't see my legs at all in the car.
It's kind of important to have it there.
You know?
I think it's...
I think it would be better.
This actually looks pretty good.
I'd say.
I think it's...
Alright, what did I put that one at?
84.
Okay.
Oh no!
I took that one picture!
I gotta add it somewhere.
Hold on.
84...
Where should I put it?
Oh, I'll put it... I could put it here.
I could put it here.
I think.
Wait!
I have an even better idea.
I have a better idea.
Okay.
It's a window.
It's a windshield.
Windshield cover.
It's a windshield cover.
Gotta make it a little bit bigger though.
Not good enough.
Let's get rid of this.
All these pesky body parts that we don't need.
Get out of here.
Oh, and then of course the headband.
Don't worry, I haven't forgotten.
I'll probably forget later.
Please remind me if I forget.
Actually, no.
I'll do it right now.
I just don't remember where I have it saved.
...
Now I remember where I saved it.
I don't know where it is.
Oh, I have it!
But uh, let's hide it for now so I can take care of this part.
...
Sorry.
Scared me.
Can't tell where the windshield begins.
I think this is correct.
It's gonna be a little cut off.
You won't see my dashing smile.
But that's okay.
That's okay.
That's fine.
Okay.
It's all good.
It's all fine.
Does the car gain any mint ghost powers?
It actually sounds like that when you drive it.
Do you know how there are some cars that...
make so much noise, they're like...
This one, everyone will know...
while they're driving the mint Miata...
You can hear it everywhere... the mint miata.
No one is safe.
I can't tell if this is part of the windshield or not.
So I'm just gonna do it like that.
And then the headband.
The radio plays exclusively Bustin'.
When you honk the horn it goes...
B-B-B-Bustin'!
B-B-B-B-B-Bustin'!
Yeah!
How we feelin' ladies?
How we feelin'?
Alright, hold on.
One more thing.
I'm gonna draw you two sideways.
There you are!
And um...
Where should I write your name?
2013...
Yeah!
Not even sideways?
You're right.
Ugh, you're right.
It's okay.
I don't want him to look like he's dead on the ground, you know?
Rotate it by 90 degrees.
But then the name... I'll have to redo the name too.
And let me zoom in so you can screenshot.
Screenshot?
Oh, uh...
Uh...
Once again, there we go.
I'll move out of the way.
Get your screenshot!
Oh, there we go.
The mint miata.
Mintata?
No!
That sounds icky.
Okay.
Thank you, Minto.
You're welcome!
You are so welcome.
It almost looks legit.
It almost looks convincing, I'd say.
Oh, wait.
I just realized this part is bad.
Wait.
That part was sticking up too much.
There we go.
I fixed it.
Take another screen.
Oh, wait.
I gotta move over.
I'm gonna zoom out all the time.
There.
There we go.
It's gotta be authentic.
It's gotta be, like, really convincing.
What am I looking at?
I just got here.
You're looking at the new, the fancy, this...
Forget the cyber truck.
It's time for the ghost truck.
The bull brigade.
The, the, the, the ghost...
Wait.
The mint mobile.
Oh, my gosh.
Thank you for the Akasupa!
Can't believe my Oshii is taking my first Akasupa.
I mean, what were you thinking?
Thank you for the Akasupa!
Thank you!
The mint Miata!
Oh, my gosh.
Oshii!
Thank you for the big Akasupa.
Congrats on 200,000!
Thank you!
The mint mobile...
There's a bit on the wheel.
This...
This down here?
Oh, I see it.
I see it.
Oh!
This on the wheel!
Oh my gosh, you're so... I'm so sorry!
Oh my gosh, it's so embarrassing.
Oh my gosh, I missed so much!
Oh my gosh, there's even more!
That's so embarrassing.
Oh my gosh, sideways please.
I don't deserve that, Akasupa.
I messed up.
I messed up bad.
I was looking at this part right here, this tiny bitty bit.
I was like, oh you're right, it does kind of stick out.
So I'll fix it.
Okay, now... it should be... third time's the charm.
Wait, third time's the charm.
There you go.
Okay, thank you.
Oh my gosh, I can't believe I missed that.
That's so embarrassing.
I'm gonna think about that for the rest of my afterlife.
Tiny bit near the front headlight?
Wait, do you mean this part?
Is that not just a shine on the car?
Fourth time's the charm.
Lucky number.
Spooky number four!
There we go.
Ka-chow!
There's a bit of... a bit of... a bit of... a bit of mint in the bottom left corner.
You know what, it's dead.
The bit is dead.
The bint of bint is... the bint of... the bit of mint is... the bint is dead.
Where do you get your mints at?
Where do you get your mints printed?
Bogo's minted?
Well guys, I think that was a good one to end on.
Like I said, this won't be the last time I do this.
Let me show you what my schedule is for next week.
Though...
Oh, whoops.
Though, I think...
I think it will probably change because...
Oops, not that.
Because maybe I have to do something for 200k.
So take this with like a grain of salt at the moment.
It's not totally complete.
It's maybe not accurate.
I'll probably change...
Wait, let us know.
Nazo can be my thing for 200k.
200k Atlantis, no Nazo!
Or is it Nazo no Atlantis?
Wait.
No, it's Atlantis no Nazo, right?
Am I losing it right now?
I think I'm very tired because I'm hungry.
Yeah, so...
Yeah, I have a collab with Lia.
Actually, she asked me to send her some stuff for it.
And I had to stream, so...
Yeah, collabing with Lia on her channel.
So technically, I won't be streaming on my channel that day.
And Monday, tomorrow...
The podcast.
And...
Sunday, I'm seeing my grandma.
So...
Yes.
Yeah, but like I said, this might change a little bit because...
Oh, and all the times are wrong.
So please don't look at the times at the moment.
Oh, wait.
Actually, only Ghost Trick is wrong.
What time did I have Ghost Trick for?
Oh, Ghost Trick is actually 6pm EST.
And Atlantis no Nazo is actually...
2pm...
EST.
So it's just a little bit wrong.
Just a little bit wrong.
But yeah, I hadn't fixed that yet.
I need to...
Get a schedule with Figma.
Because...
I'm so bad about changing the times.
It's my least favorite thing.
So I'll probably be...
Commissioning a new schedule.
So that I can use Figma again.
Mmm...
Okie dokie.
I'm gonna go...
To...
Eat dinner.
Even though it's kinda late.
I hope you guys...
Everybody who got profile pictures.
I hope you guys like them.
I'll do some more in the future.
And before we head out...
Before we head out...
Are you ready?
In a sec...
Oh...
I can...
I can't...
I can't tell you how I feel...
I can't.
Ah...
Come on.
Come
on.
Bustin' bustin' bustin' bustin' bustin' bustin' Thank you guys for 200k!
Thank you!
Keep seein' things Sleepin' in your bed Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah Invisible man Sleepin' in your bed Ow!
Let me tell you somethin' Ow!
Yeah!
Bustin' bustin' bustin' bustin' Make me feel good, feel good Wow!
Thank you for the Alcocin' Mercedes update!
Thank you!
Bustin' bustin' bustin' bustin' Bustin' bustin' bustin' bustin' Bustin' bustin' bustin' bustin' I'm drawing art Feel good, feel good Feel good, feel good Feel good, feel good Feel good, feel good Feel
good, feel good Ghost maid Freaky ghost man Freaky ghost maid Bustin' If you're all alone Let me sleep in your bed
Let me tell you somethin' Feel good, feel good Aw, yeah!
Sleepin' I ain't afraid of no sleep I ain't afraid of no bed
An invisible bed Among Us bed!
Oh my god!
It's an Among Us bed!
Bustin' bustin' bustin' bustin' Bustin' bustin' bustin' bustin' Bustin' makes me feel good Feel good, feel good Feel good, feel good Feel good, feel good Yeah, yeah, yeah!
Bustin' bustin' bustin' Bustin' Feel good, feel good Feel good, feel good Feel good, feel good Yeah, yeah, yeah!
Oh my gosh!
Mini Scooter!
Thank you for the 50!
Thank you!
That makes me feel good!
Otomito everyone!
Bye bye!
Thank you!
See you guys later!
Listen to the podcast tomorrow!
And I'll see you guys... tomorrow.
At the... at the... at the podcast.
Oh wait.
Actually I think I have a... I think I have a haunting appointment.
I don't know if I'll be there actually.
I think I have a haunting appointment.
So... If I see you, I'll see you though.
Bye bye!
Otomito!
Busting!
I feel good!
Thank you for 200k!
See you another day!
Okay bye!